in the previous video we gave the
definition of optimization
and even formulated a few problems as
optimization problems
what we have not done however is discuss
how you go about solving
such problems what if i told you that
each one of these three optimization
problems can be solved easily with a few
lines of code
and note that the code is almost
identical for these three problems
even though the problems themselves look
very different
we won't go into the details of the code
or the algorithms that's for a later
video
but what we will do today is present the
common property
that allows us to solve all of these
problems in a unified fashion
and this property is called as you might
have guessed convexit
so what is convicted
if you open in a textbook you will find
the definition of complexity in
three different contexts the context of
sets
functions and optimization problems
let's go through them one by one the
first definition relates to sets
a set is convex if for any pair of
points
inside the set the segment between the
two points
falls entirely inside the set it's easy
to visualize how a set can fail to be
convex
so for example this set with a hole in
it
fails to become vex because the middle
point falls
outside of the stand for similar reasons
this set here also fails to be convex
examples of convex sets include planes
polyhedra aka intersection of half
spaces
bowls potato shapes etc you get the idea
the second definition relates to
functions
a function f is convex if it's epigraph
that is the region above the graph of
the function
is a convex set
intuitively this means that the function
is ball shaped
or curved upward if you will
convex functions include the function x
or any linear function for that matter
the function x squared the exponential
function
etc non-convex functions
include the function x cubed the sine
function
etc and i should mention here that a
nice way to construct new complex
functions from existing ones
is to take a function that is known to
be convex and
scale it with a positive constant or
take two convex functions
and add them together the third context
where one encounters convexity
is that of optimization problems an
optimization problem is said to be
convex if
the objective function f is convex the
functions gi
that give the inequality constraints are
convex
and the functions h i are linear you
might wonder why we require the
functions h i to be linear and not just
convex the reason for that is simple we
can replace
an equality h equals zero with two
inequalities
h smaller than zero and minus h smaller
than zero
and the only functions for which h and
minus h
are both convex are the linear ones
now that we get the formalities out of
the way what is convexity really
and why do we care about it i would
argue that the crucial thing that
convexity allows us to do
is apply the principle of duality
the principle of duality is so
fundamental and so beautiful
that if there was only one thing you
should remember from this video
it should be this one duality is the
ability to view a mathematical concept
from two different perspectives a primal
one and a dual one
let's be more concrete and see what
duality means
in the three context where convexity
appears sets
functions and optimization problems
let's start with convex sets the
definition i gave before was internal
i took points inside the set and i
required that the segment between them
be inside the set too there is a
dual external definition too now instead
of taking a point inside my set
i take a hyper plane that supports my
set
this simply means that i take a
hyperplane in such a way that my set
falls entirely
in the positive side of this hyperplane
with the definition of supporting
hyperplanes in mind the
dual definition of convex sets is as
follows
a set is convex if when you consider the
intersection
of the positive regions of all of its
supporting hyperplanes
you recover the set itself
let that sink in for a moment and let's
just take some time
to appreciate the ramifications of this
definition to optimization
according to this dual definition convex
sets
are the ones defined with possibly
infinitely many linear inequalities
so somehow convex sets through the lens
of the duality principle
are polyhedra with possibly infinitely
many faces
and most of the things that we love
about the linear world
that makes things simpler extend to the
convex world with little effort
this actually reminds me of the quote of
rockefeller
one of the leading figures in
optimization theory who said
in fact the great watershed in
optimization
isn't between linearity and
non-linearity but
between convexity and non-convexity
what he means by that is that for a long
time we thought that linear problems are
easy
and nonlinear problems are hard but as
it turns
out and this is a more and more commonly
held belief
what actually makes optimization
problems easy is convexity
which generalizes the notion of just
linearity
back to duality the duality principle
can be more clearly seen in the context
of complex functions
as it lets you extrapolate the local
behavior of a function
to some global property of this function
and this statement will make more sense
in a second
if we want to talk about local behavior
of a function
we have to mention taylor's
approximation theorem
in its simplest form this theorem states
that
if you zoom in on a function around the
point x
then it would look a lot like a linear
function or in other words
the line or in higher dimension the
hyperplane given by this equation
is a good approximation of the graph of
f around the point x
and this hyperplane is usually called a
tangent hyperplane
the dual definition of convex functions
is as follows
f is convex if and only if its graph
is always above its tangent hyperplanes
the ramifications of this new definition
are huge
let's say you find the point x where the
gradient of f
is equal to zero then the tangent
hyperplane at that point is
horizontal and since convex functions
will always be above their tangent
planes
this mean that the point x is actually a
global minimizer of f
and this already gives us a way to solve
and constrain minimization problems
take the function x squared plus one as
an example this function is convex
and its gradient or derivative is two
times x
so when x equals zero the derivative is
equal to zero
so x equals zero is where this function
attains its minimum
another example of an constraint
optimization problem
is the least squares problem we saw in
the last video
to find its minimum we simply set the
gradient to 0
and then we solve for x
the third and last example i wanted to
show you is that of a non-constant
linear function like this one the
gradient of this function is a constant
given by a non-zero constant vector
and since this gradient can never vanish
we can conclude that this linear
function
doesn't have a minimizer and indeed it's
not hard to see that
non-constant linear functions are
unbounded
[Music]
notice how in all of the examples we
went from an
information about the gradient which is
local
to a global property of the function
that is that
x is a global minimizer of the function
and all of that
thanks to convexity a word of warning
here
in general not all convex optimization
problems
are as easy to solve are these three
for one the objective function can be
more complicated
so much so that it would not be possible
to solve
the gradient equation directly and in
that case
several methods have been developed to
solve the gradient equation
chief amongst them is newton's method
and
i have already made a video about that
if you're interested
a more serious problem is that
optimization problems often
will have constraints in the next video
we will explore the topic of
duality in convex optimizations further
and derive the
kkd conditions that generalize
the condition that grad of f equals zero
to optimization problems with cancer
friends
and we will see a very nice solution
technique to solve for these conditions
that is known as the interior
appointment
and that will be the end of this second
video thank you very much for watching
and
see you next time
[Music]
so